you have this beautiful son how is he
now he is 20 months old he is my biggest
blessing yeah he's a and his name is
Asad Khaled Asad your grooming your son
at this age to be in the music business
well yeah what not you even grew me but
you're you're including him yeah well I
want to bring him around my work
everything I do but I definitely want
him to be the biggest mogul ever I'm
saying right um so it could be music it
could be anything he loved to do I just
want him to be the best of the best
right and I'm just gonna feed him number
greatness but more importantly feed him
number love right I'm saying love is the
key love is the most powerful thing in
the world and love is the solution when
you raise your kid would love they could
be anything they want to be I'm saying
and it's just so joyful for me for me to
see my son smile and for him to secure
the future but I'm gonna secure the
future for him regardless right but I
want to teach them that Daddy and Mommy
work real hard so what you do is you
bring him in I mean he's in the studio
with Levi if I did your job
I say this is what I ain't you know I
had a TV show and I was behind us
amazing that my son would be right there
or sitting right beside me every show I
think that's that first of all you bet
that's [ __ ] with my son well there's
no way that's happening well I can be
here like rolling his eyes like dad's
Lane I mean you gotta start him early
I'm saying my son is only 20 months I
want him to see that if he grows up an
decides not to do it it's all love I
want him to see how hard the family
works to provide I don't tell my son
what I do for a living okay he thinks
I'm a real estate agent
never now and then he sees my face on a
billboard I'm like yeah the the real
states doing well right now here you
posted this really sweet video of your
son you asked him to help you pick a
jingle because Sharman good people who
make the the toilet paper yes asked you
to help them come up with a jingle and
they sent you some possibilities and you
were asking your son to pick the jingle
right well they actually asked us I know
oh that's my say asked him you asked my
second you know my son has a great
musical ear right and of course you know
I'm saying you know they want daddy and
you know father and son so um you know I
played on the two jingles and and
besides the jingles you know my son
really picks my singles in the studio
like if he does this or smile or he
starts doing a little vibe in the studio
I know it's a hit you're saying they're
kidding no I promise you like like I got
something coming you'll see what I'm
talking about he definitely did this and
this and all that but um and then you
decide based on that yeah absolutely
what if he's just having a sugar high
know what the timing was great okay
let's take a look at this this is you
asking your son to pick a jingle for
Charmin toilet paper let's take a look
so you got a pic which song you like and
the first song is called booty smile and
plus you know you got to start you know
using the potty and you got to start
using toilet paper
all right I saw here's the second song
that is called shiny hiny song you know
what I love about that is you're saying
cuz you know we're in the process of
teaching my son you know you know
eventually gotta take the diapers off
I'm saying and I was like you know are
you potty training right and I love that
that that campaigning that vibe about
the songs because you know the kids
really you know melodies and survives
and anything to make them happy and and
you know also you could teach them by
making them smile and I think that's
beautiful dude does he does he ever sing
the songs that other kids sing at that
age like the wheels on the bus go
another one yes yes yes we definitely
definitely listen to that too
you gotta get wheels on the bus in there
yeah yeah absolutely my son listens all
type of music reggae dancehall hip hop
R&B soul and obviously all the kids
songs but you know we just we just
surround him with greatness greatness
greatness and positive vibe yeah well no
way too late for my kids I should have
talked to you about 12 years ago we'll
take a little break we come back more
with DJ Khaled cigarette
you